merci d'être avec nous Daniel Salmon et
je vous accompagner pendant cette
première demi-heure et Ludie les
vilaines membres du groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire ici au Sénat on
va bien sûr parler du projet de loi
énergie renouvelable qui arrive cet
après-midi dans l'hémicycle mais d'abord
sainte Soline ce weekend et on a vu ses
affrontements autour de ce projet de
bassines dans les Deux-Sèvres les
militants qui ont prévenu de revenir
aujourd'hui c'est le jour de la reprise
des travaux est-ce que vous les
encouragez à revenir sur place
je vais prendre les choses un peu
autrement la question la gestion de
l'eau était une gestion capitale tout le
monde vivant a besoin de cette eau on
sait qu'elle nous fait cruellement
défaut après cet été très très sec ce
mois d'octobre qui a vu les
précipitations il manque 30 à 40% des
précipitations donc il faut qu'il y ait
un réel débat démocratique il faut que
tous les toutes les parties prenantes
soient entendues et ce n'est pas le cas
dans les Deux Sèvres et dans la Vienne
non plus c'est un problème pratique ou
c'est un problème est-ce que c'est
bassine pour vous ce sont un problème
est-ce que vous comprenez les
agriculteurs qui disent on stocke de
l'eau quand il y en a pour pouvoir
arroser nos cultures quand il y en a pas
bien entendu il faut de l'eau on ne peut
pas être contre l'irrigation mais il
faut une irrigation raisonnée par une
irrigation comme elle se fait
aujourd'hui ou comment elle va se faire
demain avec ses bassines qui sont quand
même des immenses cratères qui sont qui
sont creusés ils font quand même il faut
voir un peu la dimension 10 hectares 18
hectares 8 mètres de profondeur ça part
d'un certain d'un espèce de mensonge en
disant ça va se remplir avec l'autre
pluie alors quand les gens attendent eau
de pluie pense que c'est simplement
l'eau qui tombe qui va les remplir pas
du tout il tombe moins d'un mètre de
précipitation par an dans ces régions là
et les bassines font 8 mètres de
profondeur on voit tout de suite qu'il y
a un léger sujet donc on va pomper dans
les nappes phréatiques on nous dit que
c'est nappe phréatique se renouvelle et
quand l'hiver et sont en excès sauf que
ça fait à peu près 30 ans qu'elles ne
sont jamais en excès et qu'on tombe dans
les nappes superficielles c'est-à-dire
de l'eau qui est perdue alors on nous
dit qu'elle va être perdue perdu pour
qui et pourquoi c'est avoir et surtout
on est à une incapacité à se projeter
dans l'avenir je vous le dis on vient de
connaître un été très très sec et ça va
se reproduire donc ces grandes bassines
on le sait elles vont être remplies sans
faire vraiment attention aux
préconisations aux exigences de la
préfecture et on ne sait pas qui fera
les contrôles donc vous êtes contre le
principe de sébacine est-ce que vous
demandez au gouvernement puisque vous le
dites ça va se reproduire ces séchage a
priori est-ce que vous dites au
gouvernement il faut une nouvelle
politique de gestion de l'eau dans le
pays clairement très clairement et ça
interroge le modèle agricole ça
interroge ce que l'on va faire pousser
dans ces régions qui deviennent de plus
en plus sèches le Maïs est une plante
qui est très exigeante en eau et qui
pousse au moment justement où il y a
Badoo c'est pour ça qu'on fait
d'irrigation donc il faut s'interroger
sur ce maïs qui est pour une grande
partie dédiée à l'exportation on nous
parle de souveraineté alimentaire ce
maïs part à l'exportation pour une
grande partie donc arrêtez les cultures
trop gourmandes en eau pour vous très
clairement il va falloir il faut en
retrouver un peu parce que il y a un
équilibre un équilibre à trouver pour
nourrir les animaux d'élevage que nous
avons mais on sait que lorsque l'on
nourrit avec du maïs c'est aussi du soja
brésilien qu'on va apporter des
cotations
intérieur mais stop aux exportations de
boule de culture trop gourmandes en eau
c'est ça oui il faut il faut redevenir
sur des de la polyculture élevage parce
qu'on est dans des régions également où
on ne fait que de la céréale que du maïs
il faut se revoir ce modèle là qui nous
emmène droit dans le mur sur ce qui
s'est passé ce week-end à Sainte-Soline
puisque les affrontements lors du
manifestation interdite il y avait des
écologistes présents sur place Yannick
Jadot Sandrine Rousseau est-ce que c'est
la place d'élus d'aller dans des
manifestations qui sont interdites par
la préfecture
alors c'est la place oui c'est la place
des élus d'être là où il y a vraiment du
débat juste enfin ou une absence de
débat justement parce que si on en
arrive là c'est parce qu'il y a pas eu
de débat démocratique et je pense que
cette manifestation est légitime si même
si elle n'est pas légale on est là dans
une forme de résistance bien loin des
propos du ministre de l'Intérieur qui
parle des côtes terrorisme on est en
train complètement on est en train de
galvauder le terme terrorisme terrorisme
ça va avec terreur est-ce qu'il a il y
avait de la terreur pas du tout
effectivement il y a de l'affrontement
moi je condamne la violence mais on
comprend aussi des gendarmes blessés
pour vous on peut pas parler
d'écotérisme pas du tout pas du tout et
il y avait là des familles il y avait là
de nombreux agriculteurs du secteur donc
effectivement il faut trouver des lieux
de débat pour éviter que ça se termine
comme ça et vous les condamner ces
dégradations et ces attaques envers les
forces de l'ordre oui bah oui je vous
l'ai dit tout de suite la violence n'est
pas une solution mais lorsque on
donc ça veut dire que comme à
Notre-Dame-des-Landes vous encouragez la
création d'une date sur place pas
forcément la création d'une zone mais il
faut qu'il y ait une mobilisation qui
perdure sur presque effectivement on va
se rendre compte dans quelques années
que nous avions raison sur ce qui s'est
passé samedi la nuit que j'adore à
retrouver l'inscription crevure je cite
sur la voiture avec laquelle il est venu
manifester pour Sandrine Rousseau je la
cite il paye la manière dont il présente
l'écologie c'est interroge les
manifestants qui eux s'engagent
pleinement dans ces luttes là qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de cette réaction de
Sandrine Rousseau
je trouve qu'elle n'est pas la hauteur
on est tous ensemble sur un combat qu'il
faut mener le plus collectivement
possible on a toujours eu des
divergences avec certains activistes
également mais on a aussi une
convergence vers des vers des combats
donc ça n'a pas lieu d'être elle aurait
dû soutenir Yannick Jadot pour vous bien
entendu Yannick Jadot il est là depuis
le début de la lutte contre les bassines
donc on peut pas lui faire porter le
chapeau sur cette sur ces journées qui
ont été difficiles est-ce que ça montre
pas qu'il y a un clivage au sein de
votre partie entre une écologie radicale
prenait par Sandrine Rousseau et une
écologie peut-être plus raisonnable une
écologie de gouvernement défendue par
Yannick Jadot moi je reprendrai des mots
ce qui disent que la radicalité c'est
donner de l'espoir donc il faut donner
l'espoir il faut pas se contenter d'être
dans une niche et il faut vraiment qu'on
embarque la population avec nous et donc
il faut essayer de prendre plus large
effectivement il y a du débat chez nous
et bien on aura un congrès plutôt sur
il faut la radicalité on sait pas trop
ce que ça veut dire moi je suis radical
parce que j'estime que il y aura pas de
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
s'il y a pas de justice sociale ça c'est
de la radicalité il va falloir prendre
l'argent là où il est là où il est ça
c'est très clair mais
vous savez qu'il y a quand même les
riches se sont enrichis depuis des
décennies et surtout ces dernières
années c'est une explosion de leurs
revenus donc effectivement il va falloir
partager c'est le maître mot aujourd'hui
et du coup vous dites sur un congrès
effectivement dans quelques semaines un
repécologie les Verts quelle ligne vous
soutenez vous qui vous soutenez dans ce
congrès je me suis inscrit sur la motion
qui est portée par Marine Tondelier
parce que je pense justement que on a
intérêt à être le plus rassemblé
aujourd'hui parce que nous avons des
défis devant nous et les Français nous
attendent et ils nous attendent pas sur
des Bizzbee il nous attendent sur le
fond et parce que le réchauffement
climatique et là il est pas là pour 2050
ou 2100 et lasse et justement on va
parler du fond on va parler de ce que va
faire le Sénat cet après-midi
c'est-à-dire un examen de ce projet de
loi pour accélérer le développement des
énergies renouvelables on va voir ce que
contient ce texte avec six jour 1
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur le sénateur bonjour et
Steve examine donc à partir
d'aujourd'hui le texte du Gouvernement
sur les énergies renouvelables que
contient ce projet de loi des mesures
d'urgence des mesures d'urgence pour
rattraper notre retard en matière
d'énergie renouvelable la France est le
seul pays européen ne pas avoir atteint
ses objectifs pour 2020 les objectifs de
chaque pays avaient été fixés par la
Commission européenne en 2009 en tenant
compte de leur potentiel nous devions
être à 23% de part d'énergie
renouvelable de notre consommation
d'énergie nous avons atteint que 19% en
2020 pour attraper ce retard Emmanuel
Macron va aller beaucoup beaucoup plus
vite écouter le
trois ans pour un projet photovoltaïque
c'est un bon objectif pour les petits
projets on doit même faire plus rapide
je veux à cet égard qu'on aille deux
fois plus vite au moins pour les projets
renouvelables au moins deux fois plus
vite et c'est possible pour aller plus
vite le gouvernement veut donc adapter
de manière temporaire les textes il veut
simplifier et assouplir les procédures
administratives et qu'en pensez
sénateurs ils partagent le constat il
faut accélérer le déploiement des
énergies renouvelables mais les
sénateurs se méfient d'un choc de
simplification qui serait trop violent
ils veulent que les élus locaux aient un
droit de regard sur le déploiement des
projets concrètement le Sénat propose
129 abonnements la mesure la plus forte
consiste à introduire dans la loi un
genre de droit de veto des mers ce sont
eux qui définiront en amont les zones
d'installation des projets avant même
que le gouvernement ne prenne ses
décrets les maires pourront ensuite dire
oui ou non au projet d'énergie
renouvelable qui sont proposés et ce oui
ou ce nom s'imposera au gouvernement et
à l'état en pause on pense ça surtout au
projet d'installation d'éol qui suscite
parfois des oppositions au niveau local
Oriane et justement sur les éoliennes en
mer les sénateurs proposent une règle
simple oui pas d'éolienne en mer à moins
de 40 km du rivage l'idée est de
privilégier les zones d'implantation si
tu as une distance acceptable pour les
populations l'objectif ne pas installer
de barrière d'éolienne trop proche des
côtes évidemment cette règle des 40 km
ne s'applique que si la technologie le
permet et puis parmi les modifications
apportées par le Sénat au texte du
Gouvernement trouve aussi en vrac de
nouvelles dérogations procédurale
temporaire à l'installation des projets
la création d'un fonds garanti pour
couvrir les risques contentieux des
porteurs de projets ou encore
l'implantation de modules photovoltaïque
sur les voies feraient monsieur le
sénateur le Sénat a fait le job avec ce
texte proposé par les commissions est-ce
qu'il a amélioré le texte du
Gouvernement est-ce que ça va te
permettre d'accélérer la transition
énergétique
trois questions
et bien écoutez
il a fait un certain job il y a eu des
amendements qui vont dans le bon sens
par exemple dans les contrats long terme
c'est quelque chose qui qui a été
amélioré pour qu'il y ait un meilleur
investissement une meilleure
appropriation des projets éoliens il
faut que les élus locaux les
collectivités territoriales puissent
s'en emparer et c'est le cas avec ces
contrats long terme donc nous nous
sommes satisfaits d'un certain nombre de
points cette loi elle va dans le bon
sens puisque elle répond à nos attentes
le projet du gouvernement va dans le
sens de la simplification accélération
qu'on demande depuis des décennies par
contre on s'interroge sur le timing
puisque ça arrive avant la PPE qui
arrivera l'année prochaine et avant
également le débat sur le nucléaire donc
je pense que là on aurait pu faire
beaucoup mieux et plus pertinent par
contre et bien il faut prendre ce qui
est là et aujourd'hui comme vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure nous ne sommes pas
dans la trajectoire pour les énergies
renouvelables donc il faut y aller par
contre
vous disiez est-ce que le Sénat fait le
travail le Sénat a fait une partie du
travail mais d'un côté il a amélioré
mais d'un autre côté il bloque
complètement puisque avec ce veto pour
les mères et bien on voit bien que dans
une majorité de cas et bien il n'y aura
pas d'éolien terrestre les écologistes
ne voteront pas ce texte en l'état à
cause de ce droit de veto qui serait
accordé au maire complètement est-ce que
l'on veut
complètement complètement avec ces deux
points mais le principal est le droit de
veto des mers et l'autre que vous avez
expliqué tout à l'heure les 40 km pour
les l'éolien en mer avec ces deux
éléments là ça veut dire que l'on bloque
que l'on bloque l'éolien et même une
partie du photovoltaïque et qu'on
arrivera jamais à rattraper ce retard et
on sait aujourd'hui pertinemment que
c'est dans les quelques années qui sont
devant nous que nous devons accélérer
pour vraiment sortir au plus vite du
fossile le réchauffement climatique
n'est pas pour 2100 comme on le disait
tout à l'heure il est là et il faut agir
et ce n'est pas avec le nucléaire je
peux profite à chaque fois pour en
parler que nous atteindrons ces
objectifs là d'abord la moitié des
centrales sont encore pratiquement à
l'arrêt et le nouveau nucléaire en
espérant qu'il arrive enfin certains
espèrent qu'il arrive ne sera pas là
avant 2035 2015
il y a des problèmes d'acceptabilité des
éolienne est-ce que c'est pas normal que
ce soit les élus locaux qui est le
dernier mot sur ce qui se passe dans
leur commune nous sommes dans un pays où
nous devons avancer ensemble ça peut pas
être Jupiter rien ça ne peut pas être le
petit le maire local je vais pas enlever
petit parce que c'est péjoratif le maire
local qui décide non plus lorsque l'on
fait une autoroute lorsque l'on fait des
grands travaux effectivement il y a des
décisions qui sont prises au niveau
national nous sommes là pour qu'il y ait
une convergence entre les vues des élus
locaux et le niveau national bien
entendu et pour cela il faut une
planification nous appelons une
planification nous appelons à une
meilleure répartition également
ça ne serait pas le plutôt que le préfet
et bien on va avoir des exigences au
niveau régional dans les stradettes
ça va se concrétiser au niveau local
avec des demandes appuyées pour qu'il y
ait des projets il faut trouver les
zones qui sont les meilleures et à un
moment il faut décider effectivement et
je pense que sérieusement vu les enjeux
qui sont devant nous c'est pas seulement
le maire de la commune qui peut dire je
ne veux pas du Néolia ici surtout qu'il
y a un terme qui apparaît la visibilité
on est dans un flou artistique la
visibilité qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
l'éolienne si elle est vue de 30 km
c'est le maire qui a 30 km qui va dire
non non mais c'est pas sérieux dans
cette mesure justement sur le droit de
veto est-ce qu'il y a pas quelque chose
comme une mesure électoraliste à moins
d'un an des sénatorial
je me serais pas permis de dire mais
quand même on peut le penser les
élections arrivent à certains nombre de
maires pour répondre à une petite partie
de la population parce que lorsque l'on
interroge sur le fond les citoyens
français lorsque leur montre que c'est
l'intérêt non seulement national mais
c'est l'intérêt planétaire de développer
les énergies renouvelables les citoyens
français sont capables d'entendre ça et
à partir du moment où il y a un partage
de la valeur parce que c'est quand même
des éléments importants de cette loi le
partage de la valeur et que tout le
monde s'y retrouve pas seulement les
investisseurs et bien je pense qu'on
peut avoir une adhésion très forte du
public là-dessus il y a un autre point
toujours sur cette question de l'accès
habilité qui est que pour favoriser
l'acceptabilité il y a des ristournes
qui seront accordés aux riverains qui
sont à proximité de ces infrastructures
ils auront une facture d'électricité
moins chère ça c'est ce qu'il y a dans
le texte du Gouvernement le Sénat dit
non il faut que cette histoire aille au
collectivités quel est votre avis
là-dessus et pour une fois que le Sénat
parle collectif je trouve ça très très
bien mais aussi on est pour que ça aille
aux collectivités mais on sait aussi que
les Français attendent quelque chose qui
viennent directement je veux pas dire
dans leurs poches mais à peu près
quelque chose comme ça alors le chèque
on n'est pas forcément nous on n'est pas
très favorable parce que ça va être
difficile à mettre en place par contre
il y a deux éléments qui sont importants
c'est d'abord l'obligation pour les
développeurs le projet d'ouvrir leur
capital à tous les citoyens d'un
périmètre concerné ça ça permet déjà une
appropriation par contre on le sait tout
le monde n'est pas en capacité
d'investir donc nous ce que nous
demandons et on va porter un amendement
dans ce sens là ce sont l'obligation
pour le développeur d'apporter des parts
gratuites aux riverains dans un
périmètre donné des parts gratuites de
la société là on a une vraie
appropriation qui ramènera à quelques
dividendes et qui vraiment aura du sens
pour nous plus qu'un chèque qui n'incite
pas plus que ça à regarder le projet
avec un œil positif alors vous nous
dites le ski bloque chez vous ce qui
bloque les écologistes c'est cette
question du droit de veto et des 40 km
c'est des points qui ont été introduits
par les sénateurs qui ne figure pas dans
le texte du Gouvernement est-ce que ça
veut dire que les écologistes pourraient
voter ce texte du Gouvernement et
notamment l'Assemblée nationale
des discussions avec le gouvernement
également pour voir comment ils
apprécient ce qui se passe au Sénat on
sait que ce droit de veto fait bondir et
donc nous espérons bien que et bien à
l'Assemblée nationale on revienne à un
texte qui aille dans le bon sens donc on
sera vigilant mais dans le bon sens ça
veut dire
dire quoi de conditions c'est surtout
c'est deux points là qui sont vraiment
bloquants puisqu'on a eu des avancées
parce que nous il n'était pas question
pour nous de brader la biodiversité et
les droits environnementaux pour
développer les énergies renouvelables
tout cela doit aller dans le même sens
et même nous nous voulons qu'il y ait
une reconquête de la biodiversité grâce
aux énergies renouvelables et ce n'est
pas du tout contradictoire donc un
accord est possible sur ce texte un
accord est possible à l'Assemblée
nationale on verra comment ça sort
tout à l'heure on parlera des divisions
à gauche justement c'est tout à fait ça
sera dans le club dans une demi-heure
sur très clair puisque vous en parliez
puisque en même temps qu'il y a ce texte
sur les énergies renouvelable il y a le
texte sur le nucléaire qui est présenté
ce matin au Conseil des ministres ça
aussi ça vise à simplifier les
procédures pour accélérer la
construction de réacteurs Emmanuel
Macron il veut si nouveau réacteurs de
nouvelles générations avec une option
sur 8 autres est-ce que c'est un texte
que vous pourriez soutenir sur le
principe clairement non nous ne voulons
pas de l'accélération du nucléaire
puisque nous voulons en sortir et puis
comment voulez-vous l'accélérer le
simplifier aujourd'hui alors que le père
de Flamanville devait entrer en
action en 2012 et il ne tourne toujours
pas aujourd'hui et là c'est pas une
histoire de de simplification qui va le
faire fonctionner c'est simplement c'est
une x Smart de technologie et de sûreté
donc le nucléaire aujourd'hui n'est pas
dans la compétition c'est que 98% des
nouvelles capacités de production
d'électricité dans le monde installé
sont des productions renouvelables le
nucléaire c'est 0,5% de ce qui
s'installe en ce moment donc ces peanut
et c'est pas avec le nucléaire qu'on va
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique on en sort du nucléaire alors
qu'on aura de plus en plus besoin
d'électricité pour sortir des énergies
fossiles le maître mot qui est réapparu
dans le vocabulaire c'est le mot
sobriété effectivement on ne peut pas
continuer dans le mode de développement
que nous avons eu depuis des décennies
non seulement parce qu'on a pas assez
d'énergie mais par ce que la
biodiversité s'effondre et parce qu'on
est en train d'épuiser tout ces
ressources naturelles donc il faut
effectivement freiner il faut aller sur
une sobriété une sobriété partagée avec
de la justice sociale bien entendu et à
partir de là une fois qu'on a bien
réduit nos consommations et bien le 100%
renouvelable est tout à fait possible il
a été en 2035 qui a interdiction par
exemple des voitures à moteur thermique
et rappeler que des voitures à
électriques comment vous allez vers la
sobriété vers monde d'électricité
ce n'est pas vrai du tout c'est-à-dire
qu'en 2035 c'est l'interdiction de
vendre des véhicules neufs électriques
les les véhicules mais ça veut dire que
les gens achèteront de plus en plus de
véhicules électriques et aura besoin de
plus en plus électricité pas forcément
parce qu'il faut réinterroger nos
mobilités et ceux qui se fait
aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle
l'auto-solisme toutes ces personnes qui
sont contraintes de prendre leur voiture
le matin pour aller au travail en étant
tout seul dans sa voiture les comptages
auprès de base la métropole de Rennes
c'est sur 100 véhicule le matin 103
personnes de transporter 97 sont avec
une seule personne on va pas pouvoir
continuer comme ça d'abord parce que ça
ne va pas dans l'intérêt de l'individu
puisqu'il se retrouve pris dans des
bouchons tous les matins donc il faut
aller vers le partage il faut remplir
les voitures il faut développer notre
réseau ferroviaire qu'on a complètement
laissé à l'abandon il faut aller vers
des transports en commun et puis
développer pour les gens qui sont en
périphérie des villes les déplacements
alternatifs les déplacements doux donc
il y a moyen je n'ai pris que le prisme
du transport parce que vous me l'avez
abordé mais il y a moyen de faire
autrement effectivement il va falloir
sortir du fossile mais on ne pourra pas
électrifier comme dans le schéma qui
s'est développé depuis les 30 glorieuses
on va parler météo on va parler climat
puisque vous l'avez dit en ce moment le
mois d'octobre et le plus chaud qui
était enregistré on va aller à Rennes
chez vous pour en parler on retrouve
juste Marie Robin qui est journaliste
chargée du secteur politique à
Ouest-France bonjour Yves-Marie merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous et vous
revenez justement sur ce mois d'octobre
et c'est température historiquement
douce effectivement c'est tout sauf une
surprise au regard de la douceur de ces
derniers jours selon une information de
Météo France diffusée hier midi octobre
2022 a été le mois d'octobre le plus
chaud en France depuis le début des
mesures météorologiques en 1945 la
température moyenne s'établit à 17,2
soit 3 degrés et demi de plus que la
normale il a fait particulièrement chaud
du Pays Basque à l'Alsace en passant par
l'Aquitaine le Midi-Pyrénées le Limousin
l'Auvergne le Lyonnais une bonne partie
de la Bourgogne et précipitations elles
sont globalement pull de 37% par rapport
à la normale et se déficit dépasse même
les 70% de l'Aquitaine à l'Occitanie en
passant par la Provence Alpes-Côte
d'Azur et la Corse sing d'un dérèglement
climatique mouts dans le Doubs surnommé
la commune la plus froide de France à
enregistré aucune gelée le mois dernier
une première depuis 1880 et d'après les
calculs détiennent capitaux lui aussi
prévisionniste à Météo France cette
année 2022 présente une anomalie de 1
degré 6 de plus un degré 6 sur la
période du janvier octobre alors
Monsieur salmon les températures
augmentent les précipitations sur arifie
notamment en Ille-et-Vilaine le scénario
catastrophe a-t-il déjà commencé
n'est-il déjà pas trop tard pour agir
heureusement il n'est jamais trop tard
pour agir il faut effectivement prendre
conscience que le réchauffement est déjà
là et qu'il faut s'adapter et s'adapter
rapidement comme on n'a rien fait
pendant de longues années et aujourd'hui
la transition doit se faire sur une très
courte durée c'est là que ça va être
effectivement difficile mais on doit
aller vers là et on doit vraiment
s'interroger sur toute ces cultures qui
sont très très gourmandes en eau puisque
on voit bien que cette
se réchauffement climatique s'accompagne
de sécheresse de plus en plus importante
et là on est très très inquiet sur la
recherche des nappes phréatiques pour
pour l'été prochain donc effectivement
il faut s'adapter aujourd'hui il faut
changer de modèle il faut revoir nos
consommations
et puis à voir également dans dans
Ouest-France Yves-Marie ce dessin de
Chaunut son regard sur l'actualité c'est
effectivement un dessin de Chenu qui
montre ce matin une Joconde protégée par
un k-way aux Louvre monsieur salon que
pensez-vous de ces activistes jetant de
la soupe ou de la purée sur les œuvres
d'art bah écoutez je suis sans doute
comme vous je rencontre de nombreux
jeunes qui font qui sont dans l'écho
anxiété des jeunes qui ne veulent plus
avoir d'enfants parce que l'avenir pour
eux est trop incertain voire même très
certainement catastrophique et donc
c'est cette écho anxiété qui fait agir
qui fait aller vers des actes de ce type
là écoutez est-ce que c'est la bonne
action là il y a pas de dégâts puisque
c'était projeté TG par du verre on peut
s'interroger parce que on attaque la
culture donc voilà ce sont des actions
ou pas alors du coup pour vous la bonne
action
moi je serai pas allé dans un musée
personnellement après ces jeunes
effectivement ils essayent de faire
réagir parce qu'on ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui on le découvre pas les
études s'empilent depuis des décennies
et on va toujours vers une augmentation
des productions de gaz à effet de serre
donc effectivement il y a un désespoir
qui s'empare de cette jeunesse et ce
désespoir il va se concrétiser avec de
nombreux actions qu'on peut appeler de
résistance parce que Monsieur Darmanin
pourrait parler encore des côtés dans ce
cas là c'est son pour moi des actions de
résistance et d'interpellation parce que
on ne va pas assez vite merci Salmon et
merci Yves-Marie Robin regarde la ligne
de westfrance tout autre sujet ce sont
les États-Unis à la Une de Ouest-France
aux États-Unis le poids du découpage
électoral alors que la semaine prochaine
auront lieu les élections de mi-mandamme
merci beaucoup merci Yves-Marie Robin
d'avoir été avec nous et merci Daniel
salmon merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous pendant
[Musique]